[Music]
[Applause]
well uh Sean Gregory senior Sports
correspondent for Time Magazine did the
article on Jalen hurts kind enough to
let us behind the curtain here Sean good
to talk to you tell us what went into
picking these influencers and Jalen
hurts being on the cover
yeah so you know time 100 next is on our
view the 100 people around the world who
are kind of going to be
um are the up-and-comer the Next
Generation we have our main time 100
list that comes out once a year so these
are the folks you'll see on the main
list probably in five six years if not
sooner and you know Jalen hurts was was
perfect for it
um you know he's he's still young still
starting out his career uh made the big
game didn't quite get over the hump not
quite at the Mahomes level
um but but could could be on his way
um you know into style
um not into movies as we we point on the
story he's pretty locked in on what's
going on uh what was his reaction when
you told him what you were doing
yeah they were so they were they were
pumped I mean you know listen during
training camp getting NFL quarterbacks
to do media is not easy and so he on and
off day he was kind enough to give us
three hours or so and at a sports
training facility in Southern New Jersey
drove over and we took his picture and
talked for a while and uh you know he
was very business-like there wasn't much
hanging around there wasn't much Small
Talk
um you know he and which is not
surprising for an NFL quarterback it's
probably good good news for Eagles fans
that this wasn't like a distracted
distraction uh media trip where we're
messing around and and and getting all
this kind of days of living with the guy
it was very business-like he's coming
over for three hours and is going to
give you his perspective and then he's
on his way what don't we know about
Jalen hurts that we should
you know
um I would say you know and people might
know this but uh the the level of
seriousness that he takes this
um I was struck by uh you know
most most big quarterbacks are facing
the franchise right and they're on
message
um but Jalen was really really really on
message really locked in to a degree
that was even unusual for for the
quarterbacks that I've I've dealt with
so
um he's super locked in I mean you know
Philly might know this he's very into
cooking
um he cooks crawfish Cajun food that's
kind of his Outlet
um that's kind of how he relaxes
um and he also told me this makes the
story this didn't make the story asked
him about the Jersey Shore if he's hung
out there and stuff and you know he's
not hanging on the boardwalk but he but
he said he caught a shark off the uh off
the coast of the Jersey Shore uh a few
summers ago which I thought was pretty
impressive yeah I want a boring
quarterback I I want a guy who is hey
you know what he does that's really wild
he likes to cook Cajun food
I'm okay with that you also you had
Peyton Manning write sort of the forward
to this or how would you explain
Peyton's role in uh Jalen hurt's article
yeah so Peyton we did I did a kind of
journalistic story you know where I
interviewed Jalen and Peyton and others
and and paying himself wrote a kind of a
blurb
um you know for for these time 100 items
we usually have we try to get other
influencers writing about influencers
and you know paid made the point that he
first met Jalen
um at his passing Camp when uh I think
Jalen was still in Alabama and was told
you know just said he was totally cool
with the kids and he said the same thing
about my homes too like they were kind
of of the same era and you know very
personable worked hard and very studious
you know I the most interesting thing
during my talk with Peyton was about the
exchanges these two have
um on on text message so you know
they're quarterbacks and they're nerds
about it they're it's like they have
this other language and they're talking
plays and J and Peyton had to be
reminded of what Jalen was talking about
so Jalen would like Scribble plays on a
piece of paper take a screenshot and
then text it to Peyton Pate would do the
same thing so like I asked Peyton is it
like an app or something that
quarterbacks have that you know can help
them uh with the shorthand and it's very
old school it's like new school to
texting back and forth
um but there's this there was this
ongoing exchange this summer in fact the
morning I spoke to Peyton for this piece
um he happened to get a voice memo from
Jalen hurts that morning uh you know an
hour before pain and I spoke by chance
asking him about you know what do you do
in the Red Zone during this and that
because siriani uh their head coach I
think worked with Peyton in Indianapolis
or Denver I forgot but yeah so there's a
tie there and so you know Eagles fans
should know you know he's being super
curious super studious about the craft
of quarterbacking which might be
dangerous for the rest of the league you
know he didn't play great on opening day
um but the Eagles pulled it out you know
his record as a starter is unreal I
think he's lost in the last two years or
years and change I think he's 15-1 as
the regular season starter played great
in the Super Bowl so uh things are
looking good could you see Deion Sanders
making the main list with Time
magazine's top 100. for sure I mean you
know I I uh you know we've been talking
about Dion a lot here and I'm glad you
brought him up because uh you know I was
just reading about him before uh before
um you know we were on like he's
he's the story of college football
um he's changing the way everything
operates if they continue the success
right and so it's a fascinating Story
how how all in foxes on Colorado
um I think game day is going there this
this week for Colorado State Colorado
you know so it's they play USC in a few
weeks uh at home let's see going into
that UFC game if they're undefeated
um it's going to be dionmania to the
point where you know for us at time it's
like you know we're not paying much
attention to other stuff going on to
college football we're definitely paying
attention to Deion Sanders and the
impact he's having and how he got there
says a lot about the future of where
college sports is going what was it 10
years ago this week you did a profile on
Johnny Manziel he was on the cover of
Time Magazine yeah it's it's interesting
we were trying to figure out how many
quarterbacks we've had on the cover
since Joe Montana in 1982 and we've only
had two NFL quarterbacks so we carefully
said NFL because we had Colin Kaepernick
during the protest stuff and now we had
Jalen Hurst now you could criticize us
for not having Tom Brady and Peyton
Manning and Brett Favre and others on
the cover perfectly fair I would say
we're a news magazine we're competing
against the rest of the world there's a
lot going on some managing editors here
in the last 25 years weren't the biggest
sports fans it was really hard to get
Sports on the cover
um and then we had Johnny Manziel uh a
college on the cover and the headline
was it's time to pay College athletes
and uh it's come to fruition I'm not
saying we had a ton to do with it but I
think that when that story came out Dan
you might remember like you know there
was the momentum was building for this
you know I remember Jay billis was the
first
you know mainstream kind of I give him a
lot of credit for really beating the
drum on this there were some long
articles by historians about why this
should happen and it was kind of the way
it was going and now whether you like it
or not you know you know nil you could
call it the wild west you could say it's
blowing everything up but it's not going
anywhere it's a fairer system it's a
system that the coaches don't love
administrators don't love but the
players didn't love the old system where
they weren't getting any weren't able to
get anything so there's no going back on
this at all and Dion kind of um
epitomizes all of that
great to talk to you Sean thank you we
appreciate your time anytime Dad good
talking to you Sean Gregory senior
Sports correspondent for Time Magazine
Jalen hurts is one of the cover stars of
this the next generation of stars